mps voted for more ambitious reduction  in co2 emissions by 2030  they want emissions to be reduced by 60  across the eu  compared to 1990 levels  article 2 of the eu treaty says rule of  law is a fundamental eu value  parliament wants a legally binding  objective tool linked to the eu budget  that would prevent and correct  violations  the parliament approved new eu rules for  crowdfunding platforms to make  cross-border business funding simpler  the rules apply to providers that raise  up to 5 million euros per project per  year  in august 2020 3 million young people  were unemployed in the eu  mep's called on eu countries to inject  more money into the youth guarantee  mechanism  to help young people into work or  training  forests cover 43 of the land surface of  the eu  mups said the eu's future forest  strategy must align with the european  green deal  and promote sustainable forestry